hey guys what's up it's Jason and thank
you guys for watching and we are here
with our subscribe tell me about a
religious experience of yours something
profound something profound I saw an
angel once when I was like nine years
old really yeah we brought together
seven Christians I'm a Christian I am a
Christian I am a Christian I am a
Christian I am Christian I am a
Christian I am a Christian one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
[Music]
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
all right here we go to go to a church
yes idea that's a great question I don't
know where to even start I was going
into it thinking about myself and how I
present myself I thought people would be
like oh she's not a Christian hey chance
tell me about a religious experience of
yours a religious experience of
something profound something profound I
saw an angel once when I was like 9
years old really yeah
what was that like it was really cool it
was creepy but like in the moment like
you were just like stillness and like
really awesome in the Bible when they
talked about what angels look like it's
a very scary looking picture I was like
I don't know if I'd believe someone
being happy to see a disfigured human
being I had a really similar experience
when my father passed away really yeah
Wow oh no ok the speed round was pretty
horrifying I didn't even know what to
ask I didn't even know where to start so
much pressure don't worry we're not
watching first person I trust it was
Brandon in the very beginning him and I
were talking I was just like alright man
you and I packed till the end we're just
gonna keep voting the same person
[Music]
and you guys you guys really messed up
I'm feeling disappointed because I feel
like I was based off my overall look I
didn't say anything I was voted off you
know grace was standing right next to me
and she was really freaked out she was
just like you know I hope they don't
think it's me cuz XY and Z and I was
like okay then it's not grace I didn't
think it was wrong either but I just
knew it wasn't grace I wanted to ask you
is your church who your friendly LGBTQ
friendly yes actually there's two
pastors and one is a biracial lesbian so
Wow why did you choose a
non-denominational Church I mean I was
just born into it so my dad's a pastor
anyone else okay yeah what the peak a
pastor's kid yeah I've never heard that
yeah they usually the bad kids at your
school so there's like certain terms I
think a lot of people just know I
assumed his lack of knowledge meant he
wasn't a Christian and he was trying to
like pick up on things as we said them
how long have you been a Lutheran my
whole life yeah you know I grew up in
scandia Minnesota and like a big part of
the town was the church always baptized
there do you go to a church yeah I go to
this one out in Riverside I just started
going there about two months ago now cuz
I grew up going some more of like a
strict Church and then I kind of
branched away from it and then went back
what do you mean a strict to church so I
grew up Mormon you know I kind of had to
take my own path and figure out what
worked best for me
I definitely I've stepped away from
church because it's hard for me to find
a church especially a Baptist Church
that's accepting of the queer community
so I stopped going are you looking for
something are you actively halfway
through my answer I realized I probably
shouldn't have said that
as everyone else was like oh yeah they
all actively go to church now I was the
only one like I don't go to church now
and that's when I thought maybe I should
have kept that to myself well when I
switch churches like
people were taking it beyond judging and
we're making it big like they were like
condemning rude you read that I've
really been writing he mentioned that he
hadn't been to church in over three
years and I was just like okay I felt
like his story about being a PK and
coming in and out of his faith could
have been an alibi he wanted to hear
everyone else talk like he kept asking
them questions like he didn't want to
talk about his own experience so I think
a good question would to be like how
would you find your faith hmm all right
so I was actually an atheist before I
was Christian like I was a hardcore
atheist and I was like super depressed
like I was like burdened by like my own
life I'd say and then coming into the
life were like you're just kind of
getting abundantly filled up with like
love from other people and from God
especially so what made me go back in
the church what really like pushed me is
I had a really bad breakup and it was
like at this moment I was at work and I
watched this kid die because I work in
the ER so watching the kid die in the
family kind of go through those emotions
of like trying to let go I was like man
like there's got to be something like
that can you know make me feel full and
make me feel whole I believe that there
there has to be this higher power and
otherwise the ego takes us over and God
allows me to realize that there's
there's more than just me as an artist I
think there's messages coming to me that
I'm supposed to communicate through my
art the way I grew up I was really into
church it was my safe space I had a hard
hard home life and it was where I felt
like I could be myself and then I
realized I was gay and that was really
hard and then I took a step back and
then have come back to it as an adult
it's been a struggle but something that
I want to have I am a PK so I was just
born into it it was like summer after
fourth grade my parents got divorced and
so I was kind of like straying away you
know and especially divorce in the
church is like a huge thing so that was
really hard but I feel like that whole
situation kind of like solidified my
relationship just so I knew you know
there was always someone there for me
and my church was there for me too you
know I have no idea
[Music]
she's a PK like she knows exactly how to
answer like knows the perfect part to
play in the back she kind of mentioned
her stance on premarital sex so that
kind of like was like a red flag you had
a good question right yes so you you
were talking about how like you kind of
express yourself through art like I want
to just like have you elaborate on that
when he mentioned art as like his form
of everything I was just like it doesn't
really make too much sense cool well
like one thing I love about the church
is I love to sing
okay and growing up I like my best
memories of church we're just singing in
the choir and when I moved out here one
of the hardest things was not having a
church I think that like through my
voice through the hymns and everything
that's that's the biggest thing we were
just talking about this how a lot of the
people that go to my church have had
similar backgrounds to me which is
they've been hurt by the church maybe a
song like Oh how He loves us in the past
was great for you and then you were hurt
by the church having those memories
attached can actually make worship
really hard there was this song that
like it was a big song in my church the
Mormon Church growing up it was like
it's called I want to say like families
can be together forever man like my
parents they got divorced you know and
since that time like I can't even like
listen can't even look at the lyrics of
that song yeah so about you how was like
your experience kind of moving across
the states and so hard I grew up in a
town of like five hundred people and so
the church was everything and coming out
here and starting that hunt for one
that's like LGBTQ friendly and the right
kind of like chemistry of people and the
right kind of sermons and I started
looking and actually hearing about yours
and kind of like wait a minute
yeah
you should get one of these people are
the moles raise your hand if you think
the mole is still in the square
if the lights turn green
you voted the liar out if the lights
turn red
the liars still in the box and you lose
my mind I wonder if they go red cuz I'm
gonna feel really bad hi I'm the mole
you know what I did vote for him I felt
betrayed a little bit I definitely was
kind of feeling Andrew was like a
Christian for sure I was shocked because
Andrew he talks like a lot of youth
pastors at my church you know because
I'm gay if anyone else was gay I like
wanted to be their friend then I was
like oh he's my friend I'm not gonna
vote for him because I really believe
him
and then I was wrong that's okay oh my
gosh I really became an atheist right
after I got baptized I think when I got
baptized I thought something magical
would happen and nothing did and nothing
changed and I still felt really hated by
the church the things that brought them
into the church and into the religion
were things that I found on my own
without religion personal experience I
think is huge in the way that we
experience religion I would say that a
lot of times we look at Christianity is
like a monolithic kind of thing and that
everyone does the same thing you know
even like if you say the word
evangelical that usually means one thing
but that's not that doesn't usually
represent all Christians even the word
Christian that barely represents all
Christians I feel relieved that that is
over but I also feel a lot of love and
compassion from that group of people I
was kind of worried how this would go
but I realized that these were all
really good people today they're all
amazing
I got a question for you so was there a
time in your life where you had a
judgment about someone where you turned
out to be like completely like flat
wrong I think that's like probably every
other month every year I think we'd all
be a lot better if we were honest about
that because we're always making an
assumptions and letting our bias come
into play and you know you have the bias
until you get to the other side right
until you step outside of yourself and
ask me well why did I feel that way and
I thought this show would help us like
explore that and how our biases can come
into conflict with the truth stick
around for the other episodes they're
coming soon and follow us on Instagram
we have a lot of exclusive content there
some behind the scenes things and
otherwise comment below tell us what you
thought and we'll see you around bye
guys